so Donald Trump just got his worst
polling during this campaign so far down
to Joe Biden by 14 points nationally and
these are just unconscionable numbers
and a report from Axios about what's
going on inside the Trump White House
and inside the Trump campaign shows
panic fear anger at what's going on
so this latest poll from CNN CNN is
rated as a B+ pollster by 538 their
polling is pretty good
they have Trump's approval down to 38%
that rivals the lows of Trump's
presidency and then in terms of Biden
versus Trump for November this poll has
Biden at 55 Trump at 41 now what's
important about this poll other than
Biden's absolutely ridiculous 14-point
lead is that Biden is well above 50% if
you look back to June of 2016 in other
words this time in the 2016 election
Hillary Clinton was very rarely hitting
50% you can go back and you can find a
poll here or there where Hillary had 50
maybe 51 but in June of 2016 Hillary
Clinton was mostly polling in the low
40s and occasionally in the high 40s
with the occasional 50 or 51 Joe Biden
is now regularly polling at 50% and or
more in recent polls and that is a very
different starting point then where
Hillary Clinton was back in June of 2016
now the difference is Biden's running
against an incumbent
whereas Hillary Clinton running against
Trump was two challengers or two
potential candidates and there is some
degree to which one might expect as we
get closer to the election people will
break for the incumbent and that would
certainly benefit Donald Trump so
publicly Trump is insisting that he's
doing really well
he very often will tweet versions of
what he tweeted this morning this
morning saying quote 96 percent approval
rating in the Republican Party thank you
the source is never cited the source is
never clear but Trump posts that all the
time and publicly he's pretending that
he's doing really well and that Joe
Biden
win unless you know Democrats cheat in
the fall or something like that which is
hilarious by the way privately Donald
Trump's aides and advisors are coming to
him and telling him these polls don't
look good and you need to do something
they know how bad the polls are a source
briefed on internal polls is calling
them quote brutal and seeing a major
drop-off in independent support while
Trump's Republican support is remaining
relatively high his Democratic support
is extremely low independents have been
shifting away from Trump significantly
in the last few months the when the
looting starts the shooting starts thing
that Trump said is troubling for some of
Donald Trump's top aides and clearly
they know that Trump's disgustingly
divisive reaction to the protests have
heard him and they are saying Trump
needs to instead give a message of hope
optimism and unification and from that
recommendation came this idea that's now
being floated about maybe Trump could
give a quote major speech on race now I
have to tell you as hilarious as a major
speech on race would be from Donald
Trump I don't even know that I would
cover it normally I would you know
stream major presidential speeches but I
don't know that I would cover that it
would be merely a propaganda piece Trump
probably would barely even understand
what he was reading off of his prompter
it would be calculated to try to get a
few more points in a poll and I don't
even know that I would cover that speech
now a few insights into a zoom call that
took place with Trump's top campaign
advisers Corey Lewandowski asked the
question what is our message which is a
relevant question it's not clear what
Trump's message is right now they seemed
to settle on the idea of something like
a great American comeback theme the idea
of using those misreported jobs numbers
from last week to build this optimistic
comeback strategy for the next five
months that's going to be tough because
Donald Trump on one hand is appealing to
his hardcore base with his wild and
hateful and divisive rhetoric talking
about sending in the military ominous
weapons that doesn't play well with a
lot of people but
Trump switches to a unification message
to try to get his polling up it's not
clear that that's going to play well
with his hardcore supporters what would
be nice would be for Trump to say hey
you know what guys we failed we failed
the country has lost confidence in me if
they ever had it we are all going to be
resigning we failed we are failures and
I'm sorry that's what should happen it
will never happen they are going to have
to be removed when you get a tick and it
attaches to your body and you try to
just pull it off you can't the tick
hangs on for dear life they are going to
have to be removed like a deer tick
you're gonna have to pour alcohol on it
take tweezers squeeze it by the head and
try to get it to release its grip on
your skin and that's the analogy of how
they're going to have to be removed
these are some of trumps best worst
numbers ever but at the same time 38% of
the country thinks he's doing a good job
that is horrifying and it means he can
win in November and I don't know if the
38 percent of people who are cult-like
in their following of Trump or what he
does doesn't matter or they're not
paying attention or they don't care or
they're cognitively impaired I don't
know what it is but he still has 38
percent support he can still win and we
need to get out there and make sure that
we prevent the re-election in November
real quick I want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon who have done
something awesome they've taken all of
our favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat any more
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry they taste great
they're crunchy they're sweet like you
would expect this type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one Bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain free soy
free once our team tried magic spoon for
the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit
with David Pakman show staffers and
magic spoon knows how delicious their
cereal is because if you don't
like it they'll refund all of your money
no questions asked and you'll get free
shipping when you go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman and use the code
Pakman that's PA que ma n